hola de nuevo una vez más aquí tenemos
un espeluznante super espeluznante
expresión una vez más ver si puede
simplificar esto tener un poco de tiempo
para que para que lo hagas así que bueno
entonces es una expresión mucho más
alocada que las anteriores que hemos
hecho hasta ahora tenemos ya tenemos x
estemos x cuadrada x es más
tenemos 10 cuadradas entonces bueno está
genial esto aquí habrá algo de tentación
porque ves la sie si ves la otra xy aquí
y tal vez tú digas o bueno yo puedo
sumar este menos tres leyes t 4x y de
alguna manera porque bueno ves una
'llave' es otra y en el x el pero es
importante darse cuenta que una y es
diferente que una equis y piénsalo como
si fueran números si es igual a 3 y x es
igual a 2 entonces x es igual a 6 así
que son muy diferentes y aunque veas la
misma letra aquí no puedes sumarlas o
restar las no porque no son términos
semejantes que es lo que estamos viendo
en este vídeo términos semejantes y es
muy diferente allí
cuadrado y es muy diferente a x m ahora
ya con esto dicho veamos si hay algo que
podamos simplificar primero pensemos en
este término en el término con jane
entonces tenemos aquí menos 13 y tenemos
más términos con james claro que sí
claro que sí tenemos aquí 2 y ahora lo
voy a reordenar tenemos aquí menos 3 y
más 2 100 y ahora ahora vamos con el
término x y vemos todos los términos que
tienen x ya tenemos aquí esté más 4x y
entonces lo voy a circular más 4x en más
4x y después tenemos por acá menos 4x y
entonces menos 4x y ahora lo que sigue
tenemos términos con x cuadrada claro
tengo aquí el menos 2 x cuadrada por lo
tanto aquí tengo menos 2 x cuadrada y
tengo algún otro término semejante a x
cuadrada claro aquí tengo este término
3x cuadrada entonces más 3
x cuadrada y bueno veamos tengo algún
término con x tal parece que es el único
término que tiene x entonces tengo aquí
solamente más 2x y también sólo tengo un
término que tiene allí al cuadrado así
que aquí pongo más y al cuadrado y todo
lo que hecho hasta el momento es
reordenar esta expresión y lo puse con
sus respectivos colores basado en el
tipo de término que tenemos ahora deberá
ser un poco más sencillo así que hagamos
esto si yo tengo menos tres de algo si
yo si yo tengo dos de algo y le restó
tres de ese algo cuánto me queda me
queda menos uno de ese algo cierto
entonces yo puedo escribir lo como menos
1 james o simplemente lo puedo escribir
como menos otra manera de hacer esto
sería bueno vemos el coeficiente el
coeficiente aquí es menos 3 y acá es 2
entonces ambos tienen el mismo término
james haciendo la cuenta tenemos menos
tres más dos es menos uno entonces yo
pongo menos uno ye o simplemente pongo
menos james es lo mismo esto se
simplifica a eso así que ahora vamos con
los términos
xy si yo tengo 4x y le quitó 4x y
cuántos xy es me quedan me quedan 0 x es
nada así que podrías decir la suma de
los coeficientes 4 y 4 negativo entonces
4 más menos 4 esto te da cero tenemos
cero x es y de cualquier manera esos dos
se cancelan así que tengo cuatro de algo
y le quitó cuatro me queda nada aquí no
tenemos el término x se puede escribir
yo cero xy pero bueno no tiene no tiene
sentido está de más hacerlo no es
necesario
así que por acá tenemos los términos x
cuadrada ahora vamos con esos menos dos
más tres es uno entonces tenemos uno x
cuadrado que lo mismo que x cuadrada
otra manera de pensar en esto es bueno
si yo tengo 3x cuadrada y le quitó dos
de esos x cuadrada entonces me queda x
cuadrado simplemente aquí pongo más x
cuadrado y ahora tenemos menos yemas x
al cuadrado
términos no hay algo que se les pueda
hacer no se pueden simplificar entonces
simplemente nos queda más 2x cuadrada
más y al cuadrado y hemos terminado tal
vez aquí tú tengas una respuesta en otro
orden pero si tienes estos cuatro
términos en cualquier orden que esté no
importa estás en lo correcto así que
felicidades